[Musique]
directement moi des fois je vais
directement chez elles m'ont rejoint
parcours vos marchés chez nous clémence
rentre de l'école avec son amie naomi
son sac à dos et léger elle ne rapporte
ni manuels scolaires nikai et clémence
n'est simplement pas de devoirs
on voyait qu'elle est d'avoir était pas
toujours fait on voyait qu'il y avait de
la discipline à faire à l'école un lien
avec les devoirs non faits depuis six
ans il n'y a plus de devoirs à l'école
primaire la passerelle d'asbestos un
projet mené par l'ensemble des
professeurs pour essayer de contrer le
décrochage scolaire
le père de clémence stéphane langlois
président le conseil d'établissement et
a beaucoup poussé pour que ce projet se
réalise
[Musique]
on arrive de cinq ans en quart et demi
les en france qu'au château militants
jeunes donc dans les deux trois heures
par jour à penser que ton enfant citant
pas aussi 45 minutes et une heure à
essayer de faire des devoirs instant
leur avait dit le pont en or des
qualités avec ton enfant supprimer les
devoirs
ce n'est pas simple car les professeurs
doivent revoir leur façon de travailler
[Musique]
oui on va faire des dictées mais c'est
pas du tout que lampard juste après
c'est moi la maison qui nous redonne sur
le vendredi matin puis que finalement on
lui redemande m ou le mardi d'après ça
rappelle plus les mots on y travaille on
les met dans un contexte
pour les tables de multiplication c'est
la même chose
[Musique]
un élève qui est en difficulté il
fallait d'abord les parents sont pas en
mesure d'accompagner l'élève belle on
s'assure que ses élèves lors qu'ils sont
en difficulté obtient des bonnes
explications les bas les bons procédés
pour apprendre mais la question que tout
le monde se pose où les professeurs
trouve-t-il le temps de faire tout ce
travail en place
on avait à préparer les devoirs c'est du
temps qu'on avait à naître accord j'ai
ramassé tout sa société avec les élèves
le fort avancé le devoir prendre du
temps avec eux pour le corps géorgie
nous-mêmes phare en retour les élèves
n'aime pas les devoirs les enseignants
en général n'aiment pas plus ses devoirs
il aime pas les corriger non plus c'est
long c'est chronophage pour eux thierry
karsenti est l'auteur d'un livre sur les
devoirs normes aimant de recherches ont
montré qu'au secondaire
c'est un des facteurs les plus
importants de réussite scolaire
par contre plusieurs recherches ont
montré que l'impact et devoirs au
primaire était petit était faible dans
certains contextes dans avec certaines
pratiques des devoirs aussi on peut
remarquer dans certains cas un impact
négatif sur tout notamment quand ya
énormément de temps que les élèves
doivent y consacrer
par contre si on regarde ça a énormément
de recherches qui montrent que 15
minutes de lecture tous les jours un
impact direct sur la réussite scolaire
on voulait mettre l'accent sur la
lecture souvent c'est ce qui était
coupée calais par un bull - - le teint
clémence comme ses amis doit lire 15
minutes par jour
que tu aimes la lecture oui google
google goog o
mis sous la direction de l'école prend
bien soin d'analyser les résultats
d'année en année en français et en
mathématiques qu'on constate c'est que
l'impact est positif sur nos taux de
réussite
reste à savoir si leurs élèves sont
prêts pour l'étape suivante
on oublie souvent c'est que pour arriver
au secondaire être en mesure de faire
des devoirs d'être organisé de
s'organiser pour bien faire ses devoirs
et pour passer d'un seul enseignant à 10
ou 12 parfois il faut avoir appris à
faire des devoirs avant nous sommes
allés à l'école secondaire l'escale où
la plupart des élèves de la passerelle
poursuivre leurs études qui ont pas la
discipline de travail en début d'année
surtout amener ça se place dans l'année
ils prennent l'habitude de faire leurs
devoirs
mais au début en début d'année on voit
plus la différence entre les élèves qui
ont eu des devoirs et ceux qui n'ont pu
se sont qu'au début ça fait changement
du peuple sur deux roues puis cantons
urbains c'est ce que très surpris mais
un coup que tu étais beach boys à mobile
la chercheure france beauregard a sondé
les élèves de secondaire 1 et 2 pour
évaluer les retombées du projet eco la
passerelle leur projet de ne pas de
ligne de voir n'avait ne semblait pas
avoir d'impact sur les habitudes de
travail poussé mot négatif par rapport
aux eaux il est à gueltas verbe
alors comment expliquer que certains
professeurs du secondaire voit une
différence
ça peut arriver qu'un élève qui arrivent
au secondaire puis qu'ils fassent passer
d'avoir qui trouve ça difficile où
qu'ils soient d organiser mais c'est sûr
que pour les élèves la passerelle qui
arrive de nos côtés la raison la plus
facile à énoncer c'est de dire que c'est
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas de devoirs et
leçons à 20
[Musique]
mais malgré ces perceptions la
professeure beauregard est convaincu il
faut continuer le projet qui avait
beaucoup de gays et les enfants moins
stressé mais relations parent enfin il y
avait plus de de suspension ou de 2
retenu pour devoir non fait on a des
questions on n'aura pas le temps
aujourd'hui comme quelles sont alors les
devoirs pour contre il faut surtout les
voir autrement
est-ce que les devoirs de 2017 sont
obligés de ressembler à ce qui était
donné à ses 290 1980 c'est un synthé
dise ce qu'il faut éliminer les deux
voies ou peut-être changer le type de
devoir qui demander à l'enfant les
amener à faire des devoirs qui sont puis
plus attrayant aussi qu'ils sont
peut-être de notre époque qui vont
amener les élèves à les cheveux aller
faire des recherches il va toujours
avoir des départs à convaincre mais mon
accord aujourd'hui après cinq ans on a
encore des baraques qui pose la question
si jamais pourquoi ya pas d'avoir fait
pourquoi on ramènerait pas des dacquois
oui c'est un propos de devoirs à la
maison parce que le temps que je pensais
que mes enfants j'ai envie de passer du
temps de qualité par les chicanes et
pour changer d'avis
[Musique]
m